now the first of 9 000 Russian troops
have arrived in Belarus Minsk and Moscow
say they're setting up a joint unit to
defend belarus's borders the country's
leader Alexander lukashenko claims that
belarusa faces threats from neighboring
Ukraine and its Western allies Ukraine
accuses Moscow of trying to draw Belarus
into the war
[Music]
rying Rush Russian military vehicles
arrives in Belarus
another apparently full of Russian
soldiers
over the last few days belarus's defense
Ministry has been releasing images like
these to prove that a deal struck
between it and its giant neighbor Russia
is really happening
we arrived from the central region of
Russia well specifically I'm from Moscow
we've come to help the brotherly people
of the Republic of Belarus to strengthen
their borders and to make everyone feel
how United the peoples of Russia and
Belarus are
Alexander lukashenko announced the plan
for a joint military unit more than a
week ago Minsk has since confirmed that
around 9 000 Russian troops will be
based in the country close to the
Ukrainian border but lukashenko
continues to deny that his country will
attack Ukraine
it's no secret though that Russia's
Vladimir Putin has been using Belarus in
its war against Kiev including launching
airstrikes from there
Ukraine has already released images of
its Armed Forces said to be training
near the border with Belarus
but it had already been holding military
drills in the region before the deal
between Minsk and Moscow was announced
Belarus is Keen to show it's giving
these Russian soldiers a warm welcome
[Music]
but once the show is over no one's quite
sure what will happen next
well let's take a look at this with a
Katarina Shulman who's a political
scientist who left Russia shortly after
the War Began she's a fellow at the
Robert Bosch schnifton and joins us from
Berlin welcome to DW what's your best
guess as to why this joints of Russian
Belarusian unit has been set up
uh actually the position of the Russian
president Alexander lukashenka is one of
the most remarkable in political history
he is stranded between three entities
all of which want him away and all Each
of which is more powerful than he is uh
the West Russia and his own people and
yet he managers manages to preserve
power he has also uh somehow managed to
wiggle away from direct entanglement in
the Ukrainian War he is paying his
respect to the Russian president he is
doing all the lip service he possibly
can he is also allowing the use of
Belarusian territory for the launch of
Russian missiles but he has not given
any people to his ally the Ally that so
desperately needs more manpower as far
as it is possible to determine the
future to understand what will be
happening he will try to keep the same
policy that has so far uh been so
successful to him he will try to
continue in his unique position of the
same time uh Jailer and an execution of
his native land and the preserver of its
independence of at least its
independence from Russia but this sounds
like a step away from that studied
neutrality that you that you've just uh
outlined there this sounds like a joint
Belarusian and Russian unit that sounds
like a step towards involvement
um Beyond allowing Russia to to use his
country as a sort of launch pad
uh you know during the last 20 years
we've seen and heard so many
announcements of the next phase of
Russian Bill Russian entity Russian doll
Russian Unity uh we have seen the
creation uh and then The Disappearance
of collective bodies like the uh during
Parliament uh we have seen we have heard
so many Declarations of this kind and
yet somehow uh nothing very material
happened after that it may be that now
uh lukashenko will find it impossible to
any longer feed his dangerous neighbor
and his dangerous Ally with just with
words and with symbolic actions of this
kind but I wouldn't quite agree with you
that this looks like a step away from
this policy a real step away would be
sending twenty thousand or fifty
thousand of Bel Russian military to
fight alongside with Russia right do you
so you painted interesting you painted
interesting picture of the dynamic
between these two authoritarian leaders
so this is as as you said Alexander
lukashenko doing his best to pacify
Moscow without actually committing
himself to this war why does he why does
he want to take that view why does he
want to stay out of this war while while
patting
um Vladimir Putin on the head as it were
delivers to remain the president of an
independent country rather than some
sort of vassal to Moscow he is more than
willing to take all the money that
Moscow can give him and he's been
remarkably successful in this direction
but he wants to have his own country to
himself he is also aware that as we are
aware although independent psychology is
still more uh it's still less possible
in Belarus than in Russia but still we
do have data demonstrating that the war
is extremely unpopular in Belarusian
society and it is also unpopular among
the military
so he has managed to preserve his power
in 2020 solely with the help of Russia
and yet his independence his Serenity is
still with him and since uh February he
has also managed to stay away from
direct entanglement maybe knowing that
should he give the order for the troops
to March towards Ukraine maybe this will
not result in the execution of the order
but rather than loss of power for
himself that's a fascinating analysis
and we thank you for it to katharina
Shulman political scientist thank you
thank you